thank you
[Music]
have you guys heard about this jump off
the boat Challenge on Tick Tock is it
like off a cruise ship oh cold an
opportunity it's like when people do
this where they jump into the wake of
the boat oh yeah I heard people I heard
people die this [__] whoa
being reported everywhere across so many
different reputable sites that like four
people have died so that's what I heard
what happens is that they die yeah so
like how do they die here's the thing I
was wondering and I read I read lots of
comments on it right and all these
people were like well you know velocity
wise when you jump into the wake of a
boat at that speed it's like hitting
concrete and you break your neck okay
that is fair but what about people that
do
um like wakeboarding and all that in
those jet streams like they they they
use it so that's like they're all dead
yeah and then they fall yeah they've
died yeah so that's got to be like
farther back though right maybe like how
powerful it is right at the tail so yeah
beginning of the week so even right now
as I Google like to find like sources
for this all these sites from like India
times like everything is just saying
like oh yeah four fatalities four people
died I don't believe India times this
shit's not even true right really wait
people aren't dying at all nobody's died
nobody so who what's the point of that
then so what happened is some guy was
basically um every time I should have
done that and he's not just some guy
like it's like a reputable dude uh
something he said got taken out of
context where he was talking about
certain deaths that have happened that
had to do with people on boats but it
wasn't this also Tick Tock responded
said there is no viral jump off the boat
challenge in existence Oh I thought we
were getting old if you even look up the
hashtag there's no like spike in a bunch
of people doing anything and dying like
it's it's not a thing I would assume so
because not a lot of people have boats
to jump off of oh you don't have a boat
oh that's what about a pontoon if you
jump off a pontoon will you die does a
paddle yeah
no I think
yes you
what's another kind of a boat that's not
really more people choked on a cupcake
than they did off of a boat
I bet that's true so the crazy thing
isn't it isn't it so strange
that when something like this hits the
news and everybody's commenting it like
if you look at the posts that are not
confirmed to be like hoaxes or anything
it's just like you know what we need the
comments are full of people that are
like oh yeah man I know like this that
will happen like all these people agree
and it becomes like this big knowledge
Olympics I'm like yeah you feel better
because when you jump into a wake you
die like isn't there like a study that
they did that someone that tends to
comment on these things kind of has a
low IQ
damn I should stop commenting so much
son of a [__] I gotta raise my IQ this
is correlation to low IQ and comments
that's crazy I feel like there's uh both
you got the dumbest of the dumbest and
you got these smart ass [__] trolls
that are just having the time of their
lives in comments really entertaining I
love that yeah because I would see like
parody accounts too like on Twitter
they're so good right and guaranteed
there's hella [__] people in the
comments that are like fighting them oh
Jesus like those like like there's
parody like non-binary accounts or like
like you know body positive accounts or
whatever
there's always some conservative in
there like
pissed like talk like believing that
it's a real person and be like this is
why you live live tards or this and that
and I'm all like you're kind of stupid
dude like this guy's probably
conservative and he's playing a troll
right that happens a lot where the
conservative site posts and goes can you
believe this and that person they posted
was a conservative satire Rising yeah
like after lesbian it's like a person
that's like commenting seriously on
Babylon b or something yeah oh yeah
exactly yeah it's kind of like that yeah
yeah but I mean sometimes though it's
like really fun
the serious comments it's like really
funny the big bummer here though is that
uh not only people are like [__] what
did you call them knowledge what
knowledge Olympics yeah not only does
that happen
all these other news outlets are just
reporting the same garbage no one's fact
checking no one's looking into anything
and now it becomes real like that's
scariest books nope you guys like Snopes
I did until they got bought oh now it's
lies I can't I don't remember who bought
them but since they got bought it's been
a little bit weirder it's been psyopt
huh yeah kind of it was better when they
were indeed I mean propaganda it really
works that's why governments use it but
you tell the lie a thousand times and
you tell one truth the lie was heard so
many times that that becomes true isn't
that crazy it is crazy it's just like
what was happening with Xi'an did you
see that so you know if she is getting a
lot of heat yeah yeah fast fashion and
that wasn't real right not only for well
not that part but the part was um the
yeah the fast fashion the polluting the
the horrible working conditions all that
stuff is true yeah but then they did
this thing where they made a uh like a
fake headquarters and they paid
influencers to take trips to China
because they made it who's they she is
oh they did so they busted in North
Korea yeah and they paid these
influencers to come and like and cover
it and go here I am like everything's
fine these people are happy and it was
so obviously fake but the people that
they chose to like represent this were
put in a strange position they kind of
some people pointed out that they
purposely chose a larger girls because
they already don't have a lot of
opportunities in that field so they're
more inclined to to really stand by it
and you can't really talk [__] to large
girls Kinda Yeah Yeah because they're
strong and [__] yeah okay it's like a
good strategy though or like what do you
guess yeah so this one influencer Evil
Genius she made content about like yeah
check it out like they're happy they're
they're like everything's clean
everything's cool it's it's gorgeous and
and then all these people that's already
not weird like that's as an influencer
and they call me to do that and they're
like forcing me to say these things I'd
be like what the [__] no I'm not this is
weird they all these people came down on
her like can't you see what you're
[__] doing you're just a tool blah
blah and then she doubled down and was
like you're just saying that because I'm
blah like you know
but then because I'm fat and in charge
of my life yeah but then what happened
is the journalists large and in charge
the journalists who originally went
undercover to expose Sheen in the first
place came out and they were like we
went through all this [__] to get
footage of the real she in for you to
just fall for this and then so it she
Revisited it and then she turned around
and went I'm so [__] sorry oh well
that's good because then she's she
didn't hide behind her fatness she went
oh God you know what
I saw the truth
and just because I'm fat doesn't mean
that I can't see yeah
that's really brave for you dude turned
it around she turned it around yeah
I've been bamboozled you know what I
mean to like make a public apology is
always just really hard it is especially
because if you're big it's hard to get
from Factory to factory because those
factories are like 10 000 square feet
it's a lot
it's probably it's probably a long tour
too it's hella big
but yeah you're right like that that was
a close call where like if enough people
perpetuated that lie yeah and they were
compliant you know but were they writing
help me like was that really happening
was like it that ended up not being true
like in the tags that shit's crazy it
ended up I need a dentist and it ended
up being misconstrued but you know it's
like even with like news sites and stuff
their job is to create clicks and
headlines yeah so like truth is truth is
a maybe a byproduct of possibility yeah
it's not a main priority yeah yeah you
know what I'm saying so it's like the
four people died from this boating thing
on Tick Tock challenge yada yada and
it's like everybody just starts you
posting because it gains traction and
then everybody else starts posting
because it was gaining traction and it's
like it just turns into you know so
really comes down to
[__] shitty ass new sites I just feel
like it starts I can't believe anything
anymore it's it all comes down to that
one guy who uh misspoke because he said
uh four people at least four people have
died from easily preventable boating
accidents and and then he also in
addition said it's because of this Tick
Tock challenge but I don't think he
meant it that way
so for some specific choice of words
exactly and I think he didn't know it
was going to get so widely reported so
then they looked into it they were like
nobody's died and if they did it was
like a 74 year old guy that was like
fishing or something or it's bigger and
Tick-Tock is so huge that they're
covering their tracks people really are
dying that opinion is going to get way
more clicks than uh oh yeah India times
reporting now